being 2:30 we'll call the finance
committee to order in order to hear a
briefing from the
governor all right
good afternoon governor and welcome to
the finance committee good afternoon
chairman
Wier very sweet
um yeah there you go uh well good
afternoon chairman wer Vice chairman
Maguire and members of the committee
thank you for having me this afternoon
I'm here to present uh to this committee
my recommended budget for fiscal years
2026 and
2027 uh as I said yesterday this is a
budget for All of New Hampshire and in
accomplishing the unnecessary
recalibration uh this responsible budget
protects New Hampshire's vulnerable and
youth while continuing Investments to
Drive New Hampshire's Dynamic economy
and way of life uh this budget sends
more money to the local level and spends
more on education than ever
before it begins the overhaul of the
group two retirement system to make good
on our promise and to keep those who
serve our state and our localities uh to
make sure that we can recruit and retain
the very best it delivers uh record
levels of spending for special education
nearly a 50% higher than the last bium
expands education freedom to all public
school students uh will help get the
cell phones out of the classroom
continues the tuition frees at the
community colleges colleges and ensures
no weight list for persons with
disabilities also streamlines the
permitting process for housing and
there's certainly much more in the
budget we put this budget together the
New Hampshire way uh by taking a close
look at how we spend taxpayer dollars
and by not raising
taxes in comparison to our last budget
we are spending $150 million less in
general
funds this adjud adjustment was done
thoughtfully and in close collaboration
with our
commissioners my proposed budget
represents a recalibration of our
approach to the way New Hampshire does
business both the total amount of
spending and also the way in which we
Steward each taxpayer
dollars before we talk about the
upcoming bium we need to recap the
current bium and some of the lessons
learned from that the 21% increase in
general fund spending in the fiscal year
20124 and 2025 bym uh was it's
unsustainable while the 12% pay increase
for state employees was overdue and
important uh paying for that pay raise
with surplus funds instead of revenue
from the current banum uh put an undue
burden on the budget for fiscal year
2026 and
2027 in addition the fiscal year 2024
2025 budget that passed the legislature
uh that didn't have any money go in the
rainy day fund at the end end of the
bium it also uh didn't account for a
potential drop in revenues or off budget
spending and we have had both and while
fiscal year 24 general fund revenues
were
126.4 million over plan through the
first 7 months of fiscal year 25
revenues are below plan by 39 million
compounding the problem was roughly $100
million of off-budget spending that
occurred in fiscal year
2024 uh therefore the result of having
no safety margin in the budget the
downturn in the revenues and the $100
million in off budget spending means
that fiscal year 25 general fund is
spending is projected to close with an
operating deficit of 154.181
and an overall deficit of 81 million now
I know the legislature will address this
I also want you to know um that I am
looking closely at current bium spending
uh as it comes to the governor and
Council and we've also put in place a
hiring
freeze despite the challenges um these
challenges that I just talked about I'm
nevertheless optimistic about our
economy the positioning of New Hampshire
and that our business revenues will
Rebound in 26 and
27 uh we are outperforming our neighbors
we have the strongest job growth in New
England and new business startups are
exceeding the national average and we're
also beating our neighbors in a number
of other metrics we have a tax and
Regulatory environment that continues to
allow New Hampshire to attract new
businesses and new talent but to keep it
that way we have to protect the New
Hampshire Advantage by living within our
means and and not by not raising
taxes we must balance budget and rain in
off budget spending that forces us to
draw from the rainy day
fund this budget that I'm proposing uh
protects services for our most
vulnerable citizens we found other ways
to cut spending asking e each agency to
do more with less reducing uh some
bloated out ofate contracts eliminating
funding uh for empty desks and so we've
looked across the board and you know we
certainly understand the legislature
will do that as well I understand that
Rising costs are a concern for everyone
and some of the most important work in
this state is done at the local level
I'm proud to say that this budget sends
more money back to local communities
than ever before it also sends spends
more money on education than ever before
it's critical that we provide our next
generation with a best-in-class
education and our our budget priorities
reflect that the state will invest in my
proposed budget 98.8 million in special
education which is nearly a 50% increase
over the last panium we will continue to
invest heavily in our public schools
with more money than ever and we will
also expand eligibility for Education
freedom to every public school
student uh and we and importantly we
hope to remove distractions from the
classrooms by the way of cell phones um
getting class cell phones out of our
classrooms are going to help students
focus and master the fundamentals they
need to succeed uh we're making a
million dollars available in Grants for
school districts to develop individual
approaches uh to pursue this goal and I
can tell you this is a worthwhile
investment the research shows that
taking cell phones out of the classrooms
will increase test scores reduce cyber
bullying and frankly just improve the
communication uh with our students among
each
other in addition when it comes to
education our community colleges play a
vital role in helping Granite Staters on
their path to a good paying career over
the last three banial budgets the
community colleges have kept their
tuitions flat and they've been able to
freeze tuition uh for residents and they
have they provide a high quality
education my budget continues this
tuition freeze because I want to make
sure that the community colleges are as
accessible to as many people in New
Hampshire as
possible we have also continued to
invest in Workforce training the trades
and credent credentialing programs to
increase the workforce that we need uh
areas like electrical HVAC welding
Automotive Commercial Driving nursing
and mental health and other high demand
careers whether students choose to
pursue career in technical education a
two-year degree or further their
education after the Community College at
our University our investments are
important in helping building the
workforce of
Tomorrow our state consistently ranks as
the safest state in the nation and we
have phenomenal First Responders in this
state however we're facing a recruitment
and retention crisis um it's something I
heard so much about on the campaign
Trail uh we have a gap with our state
police we have a gap with our
Corrections Officers and I know each of
you know that locally challenges in
terms of gaps for law law enforcement
and for
firefighters our First Responders uh one
of the challenges that I heard a lot
about is that our retirement system just
not competitive anymore relative to
other states our First Responders should
receive a fair and competitive
retirement if we want to continue to
recruit the very best uh law enforcement
and firefighters in the country country
and then keep those who are serving now
this is why my budget invests $33
million in the group two retirement
system to begin to make it more
competitive and to retain our First
Responders this is done by revenue from
the transition from historical horse
racing racing uh to VT machines or
otherwise known as slots this transition
uh will also result in more revenue for
Education uh which which is important as
well in terms of keeping New Hampshire
safe my budget continues the northern
border Alliance which has been an
effective deterrent at our northern
border it provides 2.5 million in
funding for drug interdiction through
the granite Shield program it as well as
an additional million dollars for a new
Northern Shield program which will focus
on Coos Grafton Carol and Sullivan
counties uh this will help keep this
deadly poison off of our
streets we are also ensuring that the
state has the resources uh to get
Justice for victims of crimes and
support children who have been
victimized as they go through the court
system so the budget includes a funding
a continued funding for the child
advocacy centers the internet crimes
against children task force Casa and
funding to continue critical protection
for victims of crime to address a gap
created by the reduced Federal victims
of crime act funds
from our cities and towns to our rural
communities we must ensure that every
Granite Stater has access to the health
care that they need so the budget
includes uh care for those struggling
with mental health uh as well as those
with disabilities uh in making sure that
they can seek treatment and that they
get the help that they need and support
our investments at the Department of
Health and Human Services will allow us
to provide granted Staters uh with
access to critical Services over a
billion dollars uh proposed for the
badium to fund services for Citizens
with developmental disabilities uh to
ensure that there continues to be no
weight list $10 million over the banian
for the uncompensated care experienced
by our community mental health centers
to ensure that they remain an adequate
and important safety net uh for
Behavioral Health Services and support
in our state we also found areas um in
addition to make responsible adjustments
that bring us in line with the times and
what other states are doing uh we
brought our adult Medicaid Eligibility
back in line with prepandemic levels so
back to 2020 and we joined our neighbors
and requiring nominal co-pays for those
who are receiving
benefits we will continue working
together uh to meet the physical and
mental care needs of our rural
communities people with disabilities our
senior senors and everyone across our
state our state's most critical economic
need is more housing for our Workforce
for our seniors for our families for all
of New Hampshire you've all heard about
it um my budget streamlines permitting
and creates an efficient and firm 60-day
process we've got to get more building
done get it quickly and build housing of
all forms we are in The Proposal in my
budget uh reduced reducing our
permitting system from a fragmented and
uncoordinated approach involving four
agencies to two state agencies who will
coordinate in a transparent process we
will consolidate the permitting review
operations currently in fish and game
and the Department of Natural and
cultural resources into the Department
of Environmental
Services this will allow for a more
efficient transparent permitting process
that will give homeown owners and
Builders an answer within 60
days it's the first step in ensuring
that we are a good actor as a state and
set a model for local communities to
follow as we respond to the critical
housing shortage that our state
faces to maintain our standing as the
beacon of the Northeast and adjust to
the revenue environment that we find
ourselves in uh some recalibrations were
needed but we have been very thoughtful
in this budget and taking care to ensure
that these recalibrations are not felt
by those who depend upon us the most I
look forward to partnering with members
of this committee and the legislature to
ensure that we meet Our obligation to
deliver a responsible balanced budget to
rein in off- budget spending to make
sure that we take care of those who
depend on the state for critical
services and are our most
vulnerable and to deliver for everyone
in New
Hampshire together I know that we can
work to craft a a budget and I believe
my proposal does that and I look forward
to working with each of you on your
ideas to make sure that there's even
greater prosperity in the next bium for
our great state thank you for having me
this afternoon and I look forward to
answering your questions and Happy
Valentine's Day to
everyone thank you Governor we
appreciate your leadership and we share
your goals to keeping New Hampshire
great as you know the bottom line we
deal with comes from the house Ways and
Means Committee that's that's our limit
on what we can spend so it gives us a
challenge and preliminarily there's been
a difference between what they see as as
revenue and what your budget proposes so
we may have to be making some further
adjustments as we go and I hope you will
support them but so far I don't think
that U slot machine thing has been
passed so we're waiting hopefully while
we're in the process maybe that will
become law and those may go forward Mr
chairman I can say also that our Revenue
estimates or were based on you know in
consultation with the Department of
Revenue Administration and the um Chiefs
uh the state's Chief Economist Brian
gotle and we brought everyone together
around the table for those estimates
that are contained within our
budget very good questions from
committee members
yes representative Mari there you go
it's only been eight years
right thank you Mr chair and thank you
governor for being here and for giving
me something to do on an upcoming snowy
Sunday well yeah that that's a lot of
reading on a a lot I have a you notice
the front of it is Pink So it helps so
there I appreciate the concern the
consideration there so um if you can
help me regarding the expansion of the
EFA program can you help me reconcile
your design desire for belt tightening
and being fiscally responsible while
responsibly stewarding The public's
money with an expansion of a program
that to my mind has no guard rails
unlike other similar programs in the
state has always come in way over budget
and doesn't have an accountability
mechanism um these this tax pair of
money that we're you know talking about
and so can you help me address some of
those issues so our representative maray
I can say this first of all uh we are
making a historic investment in public
education so there is
more money in this budget invested in
public education I'm the product of
public education as is my husband so I
certainly believe very strongly in it
and we've invested in this budget same
thing with special education as well uh
if you look at these numbers in terms of
Education
Freedom I'm a huge fan of the public
schools and they do such important work
but not every child is succeeding in our
public schools and so providing
education freedom for any student who's
in public school will give every child
the opportunity to succeed in the
setting that is best for him or her and
I think that's a very worthy investment
for our state especially as we look at
our overall investment in education and
our continued uh support and focus on
our public schools which will
continue representative Ms thank thank
you Mr chairman and U thank you governor
for uh for coming in and thank you to uh
you and your team for putting in the
time to uh put this budget together I
know it's not easy um and uh we we we
certainly appreciate it I also know that
in order to put the budget together
there has to be a delicate balance
between State revenues General funds and
federal funds with that in mind um what
what portion of the federal funds
assumed in this budget are at risk if
the administration in Washington um um
moves forward with the freeze on federal
funding uh well representative thank you
for the question and and and you've also
reminded me that I need to introduce the
most important person that helped me
with this which is James Jerry so I
apolog my my budget director who put in
a ton of work on this budget and I'm
very very grateful to so glad to have
him here with me today and I I will say
in terms of uh your answer we have built
a a budget based on what the revenues we
have now and the opportunities we have
and uh you know certainly I'm confident
in where we are with our federal
revenues and and and I will say that
we've also been in touch with the White
House to get further information but the
budget that we have proposed to you uh
right now the funding is continued for
those
areas representative Lehman for a
question thank you Mr chairman and nice
to see you I think in my nine terms this
is probably the most challenging budget
I've seen so uh thanks for your efforts
to put it together and I guess I
appreciate your optimism about revenues
because as you know uh business revenues
are down by over a 100 million liquor
revenues are down and for me I don't see
that changing but my question U is
something that doesn't get a lot of
attention like our our bridges you can
see they have a weight restriction on
them but our dams in the state which we
have like 260 sad that are controlled by
the state you have about uh 10 million
doar I believe in that line item and
based on a recent report that was done
we need about $400 million to address
these hazardous dams that exist across
the state I didn't know if you might
have a plan or at least plant the seed
of how we might address that failing
infrastructure with our dams yeah um I'm
you know I I appreciate the question
representative lman and we'll let you
know that uh there there's also some
resources that we proposed in the
capital budget I will let um James speak
to that yeah we have about 13 million in
the capital budget that that's an
addition to to that money uh and we are
working with the uh Department of
Environmental Services to to address the
damn issues they have certainly brought
that to our attention uh they believe it
is a a serious problem with a very large
price tag and uh we're going to be
working with them over the next year to
uh to find ways to to fund that problem
one of the things they're looking at are
are in increasing the the fees in dams
and we've agreed to uh a possible 10%
across the board increase on those
although that's not final yet and uh
they they you know asked for something
significantly higher but uh we know we
want to go too much too fast and so
that's one of the ways that will pump
more money into the system uh if we go
with that recommendation in order to get
the uh more repairs done on those dams
but we we do recognize that that is a
problem thank you and thank you Mr
chairman representative Edwards for a
question uh thank you Mr chairman thank
you U Madam governor for taking my
question I um I think with uh the it's
it's a little unfortunate on the timing
of the budget given the enormous change
that we're looking at in DC I mean other
than the Department of Education and the
HHS nothing much is happening in DC
that's going to affect us but uh but on
a serious note with so much change I
think we have a potential for great
opportunity as well terms of waivers and
block grants and with your experience in
DC I I'm hoping that that you're you're
making an early prioritized trip to go
down and advocate for the kinds of
federal changes that we'll really we can
really leverage here uh well thank you
representative Edwards I'm actually
going to the National Governor's
association meeting next week uh in
Washington and we're going to have an
opportunity trying to meet with some of
the cabinet officials there that were're
able most of them just got sworn in so
we're going to see who we can meet with
and uh and advocate for New Hampshire
and one of the things I hope to Advocate
across the board is that if you send us
the same amount of resources but block
rant them I believe that we can get more
done for the people of New Hampshire and
do so effectively working with the
legislature on how we spend resources so
if that's a decision made um I can tell
you that we can stretch the federal
dollars a lot further than the a lot of
the you know kind of restrictions they
put on funding in Washington we could do
it the New Hampshire way thank
you representative Mooney for a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you Governor
it's always a pleasure to see you
excellent address yesterday excellent
presentation today your priorities are
spoton we've heard about all of these on
the campaign Trail housing education it
goes on and on and you've hit it all
here the level of detail
fantastic you mentioned one new position
and that was in the Cold Case unit in
the AG's office I remember in the early
days meeting with you as AG to discuss
the implementation of a Cold Case unit
so my question is why the need for the
position is it because cold cases have
increased or the workload increased
thank you yeah thank you representative
Mooney I appreciate it and I will say we
did fund an additional full-time Cold
Case Investigator uh for the Attorney
General's office in this budget and but
we also did it uh we were able to shift
some funds so we did it in a fiscally
responsible way uh the reason I I put
that in the budget is having been a
former murder prosecutor myself and
having met with several victims of crime
and Cold Case uh victims and families on
the campaign Trail I heard about the
need to really put more resources into
looking at these cases these cases are
often challenging but when you re look
at these cases and you dig into these
cases further especially with new
forensics and new new um you know
investigative techniques you can solve
them and so I felt this was an area
after speaking with the attorney general
and also hearing from victims uh on the
campaign trail that we should invest a
full-time investigator to really focus
on these cases and hopefully we can
solve more and give closure to these
families representative walner for a
question thank you Mr
chairman and so nice to see you and
thank you for uh joining us this
afternoon Governor I have a couple of
questions about Workforce sure um one I
wanted to know if there in your budget
is included a pay raise for the state
employees yes there is the one the the
collective bargaining the one that's
already been bargained or are you asking
for a future let me clarify that uh that
is not in this budget so it's the the
one that was just bargain and of course
adhering to the collective bargain
agreement of the increase that came I
believe was a 12% that is funded in this
budget and my other question is do you
anticipate in this budget um unfunded
any filled
positions in this budget um I think are
you asking me whether there is anyone
who is laid off in this budget is that
the so there are four so there are eight
positions uh across state government
four in the department of administrative
Services due to the end of a program and
then there are four in doit as you know
the way doit works it's transfers from
other agencies uh so in reducing funding
so there are eight positions and I can
tell you that I've been in touch with
the head of the sea I have a hiring
freeze in place but I have said um that
if there are positions that open up to
that those eight individuals can be
rehired in state government I will wave
that hiring freeze to make sure that
those eight individuals are taken care
of um and so that they can continue in
state
service representative PRI for a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you governor for being here and happy
Valentine's Day well thank you um in
your speech you mentioned um the need
for more housing in the state and you
have provide us with a streamline
regulations initiative and I think
that's a great idea uh and uh but also
what we need and what we've been hearing
from our constituents is the need for
affordable housing and affordable child
care
and I don't see anything that mentions
how we're going to achieve that can you
um talk further about that uh
representative I I will say this week I
had the opportunity to uh visit a great
example of how we can partner with local
communities and why permitting is so so
important and it's why it's in my budget
uh
because time is money and on these
projects and with inflation and other
contexts prices can go up so in Kean
just recently I was there with the mayor
Khan the mayor of Kean uh also a private
developer uh the city councilors were
there I think it was Tuesday or
Wednesday I was there uh they have
created small homes and they've actually
moved in four or five seniors that were
displaced from their homes from flooding
and one of the things the developers
told me there is like keep keep it up on
the permitting because they were able to
do that project in seven months because
Kean was so Cooperative uh and the
faster we can get these projects done
the better and that's why permitting uh
is in my budget but the way we're going
to create more and these are affordable
units affordable housing but the way
we're going to create more affordable
housing is uh to make sure that a when
you want to invest in it you get a quick
answer so you can get it done B uh I
plan to also bring people together to
build those kinds of Partnerships
uh Partners from Partners from like New
Hampshire housing on the finance HUD on
the federal level and also uh local
communities along with this making sure
the state's a good actor I think that is
how we're going to drive more affordable
housing and I saw many examples on the
campaign trail of this for example there
was a great project in Rochester that
brought a number of affordable housing
units online and that was a combination
of New Hampshire housing HUD the state
and private development and so I think
that's the way we're going to do this
and that's why I emphasize permitting on
this because I heard so much about it as
I was meeting people out on the trail
let's get that done uh and then also
let's make sure um you know that we can
build those those types of Partnerships
to build more housing and this is an
issue that's not partisan it's just
something we all need to work on
together yeah represent if I could if I
could add that uh the governor had us
meet with with neighbor Works uh this
week which provides a lot of the
low-income housing through the state and
and that meeting was very beneficial
because in in addition to uh funding
which which they definitely need uh so
which is which is why we have uh funded
the low-income housing fund which is why
we've extended the housing Champions
funding uh and we've worked with the New
Hampshire housing to make sure they've
had the bonding capacity
uh certainly for the for the first part
of 2025 we'll continue to work with them
throughout the year to make sure they
have the bonding capacity to do it but
in addition to funding one of the things
they've said which which works right in
with our 60-day permitting uh plan is
that what they run into is the not in my
backyard type thing where uh you know
everyone wants low-income housing just
don't put it near me And so we're going
to have to really work uh a lot harder
with municipalities to come up with
plans to uh you know enable these these
housing projects to get built and that's
what the governor's plan I think that's
a misperception too because it's it's
Workforce housing these are our friends
these are our neighbors these are these
are the teachers these are the
firefighters the policemen these are you
know the people that are building um you
know working in The Local Company that's
building something important for all of
us so I think we need to make sure we
get the right terminology too when we
think about our housing well followup
yes thank you Mr chairman and thank you
again for taking my question all of
these are great solutions to the problem
of affordable housing I used to be on
the board of directors for neighbor
works and I know that's it's a solid
organization what about daycare centers
child care this is a vital issue for our
Workforce making sure that it's
affordable for our working granded
stator so I would say about child care
two things um you know the
legislature extended the eligibility of
the child care scholarships that
continues in this budget and that's been
really helpful to many families in
addition to that uh one of the things
when we think about the credentialing uh
resources and investments in our
community colleges that will also be
used to focus on our child care
Workforce representative Sweeney for a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you guys governor for being here and for
the budget proposal just to Echo the
comments on permitting reform I can
speak as the town of Salem for years
this town has aggressively approved
projects that have then languished in
state permitting so I I believe that
60-day window is going to be a game Cher
for the State of New Hampshire and
certainly uh in combination with the c
Pacer legislation that we're sending to
your office uh come July 1st with the
60-day permitting and C Pacer we can
really see a historic era of development
for the State of New Hampshire um and
that's going to impact secondhand effect
on the revenues from the business taxes
and whatnot just curious if your
revenues are predicting any changes from
those efforts or if that's going to be
above and beyond what we're seeing in
economic growth for the next two years
we didn't account for that in our
revenue and and I do want to commend you
for passing that legislation the C Pacer
I look forward to uh having that come to
my desk I think that was a very
important bipartisan effort uh so I
would say that our revenue is really
focused on our economic growth our new
startups but the more housing we have of
course it's going to all come together
because as we one of the issues as we
Recruit new businesses here or they
choose to locate here they need housing
for their Workforce that's critical and
so it is all related uh but really our
Revenue estimates and thinking there's
going to be a rebound with regard to
business taxes is just the data that we
see underlying um here in New Hampshire
and we're you know we are I'm very
optimistic that we're we're going to do
well in the next B any you know the last
coming into this obviously was quite
exuberant uh so it will be a
recalibration but I think that business
revenues will R
out yeah if I could add just a little
bit on the revenues uh as as the
governor said um we we really put uh
commissioner uh Lindsay Steep and and
and Ryan gotlib in a room and said you
know because I I know a lot about tax
collection I know a lot about the
economy but there's no one who knows
more about tax collection in the state
than commissioner stepp does and there's
no one knows more about the new hamper
economy than Brian gotb does and so
putting them two together and coming up
with with this range uh I think was was
a great step and uh I had a nice
conversation with the chairman of the
the house Ways and Means and we
discussed our where we are uh I think uh
anything within those ranges are
reasonable although we do disagree and
one of the reasons why we disagree is i
i i caution against what I call recency
bias is that what's happening now is
going to go on forever that what we have
here now is uh you know going to
continue I use a sports analogy and I
can bring the Patriots up uh a few years
ago when they had uh they got they they
were Stillen Brady was there there were
they got beaten badly by Kansas City one
day and everyone was saying that that's
the end of the dynasty that was it
there's no more hope that was the onto
Cincinnati comment that he's become
famous for and since then they played in
four more Super Bowls and won three of
them so it's it's it's it's a matter of
thinking that what's now is going to
always be I think the New Hampshire
economy is as strong as it's ever been
it's becoming more Diversified by the
day I mean literally we have gone from a
state that has been dominated by paper
mills to where we are now growing human
organs that's the difference this state
has has been transformed over the last
few decades and uh we we see that
continuing the governor has said uh
rightly that we are outpacing everyone
in New England as far as job growth goes
and uh we we see that uh with the
changes that uh have been made over the
last decade or so and with the changes
we're going to make now to uh encourage
his businesses to come into the state
that that will continue and that uh
revenues will reflect those uh changes
thank you representative tki for a
question thank you very much Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question uh we
touched on this very briefly but um your
discussion of transitioning to slot
machines um we're talking about $127
million in Revenue which is which is
quite robust so I'm just curious how
this would impact our existing
charitable charitable gaming program and
the nonprofits that rely so heavily on
this um these funds thank you it's a
pretty significant increase for the
Charities as well because it's an
increase for the law enforcement but an
increase for education and also an
increase in revenue for the Charities
because the
transition I didn't know a lot about
this but now I learned more um that to
VTS from historical horse racing is just
it the revenue is going to be much
higher the estimates according to the
lottery uh commission and so that is
where we got those numbers but the
Charities will benefit from this as
well represent Stringham for a question
yeah thank you for coming and and we
share uh your goals as well I appreciate
uh your time with us yesterday and today
um inflation is still uh a factor as as
you've mentioned even though it's down
from where it was um my question relates
to the Medicaid rates uh we're uh some
of them are are uh already uh low enough
where uh it's difficult for the people
we count on to provide services for the
Medicaid uh patients and the Medicaid
waiver patients uh to keep them up we
were able to make some Target
adjustments significant adjustments uh
last term uh uh so the questions I have
related to that are are the base levels
for this budget uh the same as they are
now and is there any funds available for
uh rate increases in areas where uh we
think um uh service dislocations will
occur and then uh if it's okay I'll
follow questions on the Medicaid co-pay
question sure uh and I'm gonna also have
James follow up but the the rates are
where you put them so um that's
contained so we haven't brought back
rates uh to Prior levels yet there were
increases in there and those are still
in this budget um and there were some
areas that uh and that's why I'm going
to turn to James where we made some
calibration upward as well um I'll just
give you an example I just remember well
which is uh you know for homeless
shelters there was federal funds used
they received what was it $20 a day per
individual they were taken care of and
then arpa funds were used to supplement
to bring them up to $27 a day uh so I
maintain the $27 a day for example on
that even though it was only funded
through arpa as opposed to the general
funds because I just thought that was
really important as we think about our
homeless shelters and um and I'm sure
that's still very difficult even with
the $27 a day so that is an area um and
then there are other I believe areas but
I'll I'll defer to James on that yeah
that was that was that was obviously a
large one because that that money that
was was arpa funed and and wasn't in the
budget so we have to if if we flat
funded it it would go back to the $28 a
day instead of the 27 that they that
they clearly need so the governor funded
that at 27 a day the what uh the
governor's budget focuses on uh in in
addition to maintaining the the flat
level funding for for the for the rate
increases is the fact that what the
uncompensated care has done to some
providers really and not only the uh The
Fairly qualified Health Centers but the
Community Mental Health Centers as well
and in fact that the governor has uh
asked for an appro ration of $10 million
$5 million per year to help the
community mental health centers with
their uncompensated care uh that is a
significant problem we are concerned
that if they don't get this money that
they could go under which would be an
absolute disaster for the state um we
have made great progress in the mental
health area in in eradicating the weight
list from the hospitals from the
emergency rooms and bringing them back
into care and making sure that the
Community Mental Health Center ERS has
uh their resources enough resources to
uh meet their needs going forward is a
is a big priority of the governor and
that's why she put in the $10 million
there thank you U followup you have a
followup yeah again related to Medicaid
is the co-pays and um uh you know
obviously that hasn't been through a
policy committee here so I'm wondering
to what extent we think the um uh the
amount that we'd be asking Medicaid
recipients to pay and co-pays uh would
be affordable uh and uh does it make the
you know program are we concerned that
make the program uh benefits
unattainable for some of the people are
in progam sure um so all the co-pays are
capped at a maximum of 5% of income and
for some categories of individuals it's
only at the higher income levels versus
complete eligibility and in addition to
that uh we looked at this and I asked
what happens nationally on this there
are 18 other states that do this uh so
uh including some of the co-pays that
even Massachusetts puts in place so we
um you know we felt that this was done
kind of looking at other National models
to make sure we would do it in an
appropriate way uh that still made it
affordable for the individuals that of
course need this
Care thank you representative eel for a
question thank you very much Mr chair
and Happy Valentine's Day um I have a
question but I I want to start out by
saying how much um I appreciate the fact
that you put a moratorium on uh landfill
uh permitting for a year um I'm the
chair of the state Solid Waste working
group and I've worked very closely uh
with Dees and I look forward to
continuing the work with Dees and you to
retain our L landfill capacity and
reduce uh sources um I know it's a very
emotional subject for a lot of people um
my question and I know that you're very
um interested in in making sure that
every that Justice is done in the state
of New Hampshire my division uh division
one we had an opportunity to meet for an
hour and a half with the judicial branch
and we talked uh quite a bit about their
budget um they did meet a target of 4%
decrease in their budget but the way
that they did it is
concerning um it does involve the
closure of two circuit cour houses one
in Candia and Claremont they're talking
about um eliminating jury trials two
months of the year in the superior court
and they've talked about um having to
reduce security which in and of itself
may not seem like much but when you
don't have adequate security you can't
um run your courtrooms uh coupled with
all of that is the fact that virtually
all the YDC claims um they do have the
alternative uh route a settlement route
um there they have these folks have also
um filed in Superior Court so they have
something like
1375 Superior Court claims so it's
really their Staffing is really affected
by that all in all um I think that it
does affect the administration of
justice all these courts that is
Rippling out across the uh across the
state and I wondered if you could
comment on that yes thank you uh first
of all I have great respect for the
Judiciary having been uh a prosecutor
and appeared before every level of court
in this state uh many times uh but I
just respectfully disagree with them um
in terms of what they had proposed for
you um in those cuts when we we've asked
them to reduce which we did of many
agencies 4% and that 4% reduction was on
a histor historic high and I will have
James give you the exact numbers of how
much of a historic high it was coming
off the last bium and um the the idea
that they would propose eliminating jury
trials to me um when I would urge them
the Judiciary runs itself and so it's a
separate branch of government so I
certainly can't tell the Judiciary what
to look at but if I were in the
Judiciary there are two separate
administrative uh function F in within
like two separate complete
administrative functions for the circuit
courts and the superior court and they
haven't yet looked at can we share
functions uh do we need as much
administrative staff to have two
separate essentially administrative
functions rather than consolidating them
for one court system and seeing if they
could find savings there rather than
cutting jury trials uh coming off a
historic number so I'm very respect ful
of the Judiciary and I have great
respect for their work uh but I would
say I would ask the Judiciary to look at
how can we do this in a way coming off
of historical funding um when we're
asking only a 4% reduction to do so
without impacting the most important
constitutional function uh jury trials
when it comes to our Judiciary and
giving people access to our court system
so I can have James fill you in on the
numbers because I looked at this very
closely because I care about the
Judiciary
yes thank you
um it it was a 4% reduction that that we
asked for and of course the judicial
branch maintains uh some autonomy from
from the executive branch so uh we don't
have the discretion with their budget
that we do on many of the executive
agencies that that we deal with just to
put their number in perspective a 4%
reduction off their adjusted authorized
would be $116 million a year in 2024
their actual spend was 105 million so
we're asking them to go from 105 million
to 116 million which is 4% less than
their adjusted authorized amount but
it's still a significant amount higher
than what they've been spending so um I
I think there are uh certainly ways to
get there without some of the
Draconian uh measures that they've
proposed you know I think those
obviously those
uh those cuts concern the governor as
well so uh we we look to working with
the legislature to and we hope to work
with the Judiciary but obviously they're
a separate branch and I respect that
they have to make their own
decisions represent McGuire for a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
your
Excellency um revenues in the current
fiscal year have been disappointingly
below plan and um you are authorized to
make
Cuts right now um to help make the the
expenses meet income and therefore
avoiding using the revenue stabilization
fund this particular this budget has a
significant chunk taken from the revenue
stabilization fund do you think you
might be able to make some Cuts in the
ensuing months to to mitigate that uh
well representative McGuire it's you
know one of the reasons I put in place a
hiring freeze because we're scrutinizing
every position that's being hired
obviously with a waiver for Public
Safety we've got uh you know we actually
would save money if we could hire more
Corrections Officers rather than paying
overtime and then obviously Troopers and
then if you're a child protection worker
we want to make sure you continue your
work if you're directly serving people
but in terms of managerial functions and
other jobs we're that's why I put that
in place so that we can scrutinize and
then also as contracts come forward I
and spending comes forward at the
governor and council meeting we are
asking all of these questions of our
agencies can we do more with less is
this necessary even looking at things
like um you know out ofate travel we've
talked to our commissioners about that
and really trying to save money there uh
in addition to that we've also looked at
um you know we all belong you know the
state belongs to a number of uh outside
organizations some of them are very
important for you know whether there's
certain organizations in the
transportation area we get but do we
need to belong to you know 15 versus you
know one or two of the most critical
ones so we're looking at at those areas
as well they're smaller areas of
spending but they can make a big
difference so we're trying to look at
that and think about that because we
know that the current um even though I
propos to you a budget for the next bium
I know we've got to get through this
bium as well thank representative
Edwards
thank you Mr chair and thank you again
for taking my my question I I um two
topics came up co-pays for Medicaid and
uh uh onetime using onetime money for uh
operational expenses I I I I just wanted
to point out that in the the last term
we established the adult Dental Medicaid
Program and we used onetime money we
used cenen settlement money to to get
that going I view are doing that as a
pilot project believing the theory that
uh Dental Care is good health care and
if we can get our Dental cases mitigated
early we can reduce money on over later
health care expenses related to Medicaid
that was the operational theory of that
pilot Dr sarapin works for you and I I
would just ask um um the executive you
know given that I'm already looking at
next budget that would have to become
operational money next budget so if we
could just be uh keep our eyes open on
whether or not that's a that's truly a
value added program I I think it is that
was the theory but uh have you heard of
it or looked at it at all the adult
Dental Medicaid Program uh
representative I will I'll meet with the
director now that I you know certainly
you've raised it and I understand the
connection between dental care and
medical care and some of the acute
medical conditions can be related to
dental areas so I understand why you
would uh obviously want to focus on that
so I will follow up uh with the director
directly so so I just wanted to also let
folks know that we we have precedent in
the state for doing um copay for
Medicaid uh we did that with the adult
Dental Medica Medicaid Program so it's
not completely something we have no
experience with it's something that we
are already
doing committee members we've reached
the a lot of time that the uh Governor
has able to to give to us so I hope that
uh and I'm impressed with the fact that
she stayed here longer than most
Governors do and is C I didn't know any
better you certainly know the subject
thank you we appreciate you being here
and we thank you very much
are these really for me thanks of course
from the committee candy there that's
the only time we're going to give you
money like
candy you just want me to come back I
know so you gave chocolate
anytime thank
you okay
okay committee if there's no other um
things to come before us then we can
adjourn does anybody have anything else
they want to add we thank the LBA for
getting us the budget books to everybody
happy
reading it'll keep you busy for the next
six weeks and anything
else okay we are adjourned thank you all
for your attendance